I don't know if you following the story
on what's going on in Panama Canal but
it's very problematic 40 percent of the
stuff that you and I buy comes through
the Panama Canal and due to the drought
that they're having over there ships are
waiting just in July was taking five and
a half days to six and a half days for
ships to Transit through whether it's
the Northbound or the southbound Transit
that five and a half to six and a half
days is now 18 to 21 days and you and I
are buying this stuff so a lot of ships
have to go all the way around big
problem a couple years ago if you
remember what happened to Suez Canal
that's a great case study to see how bad
it's going to be here we're going to
take a deep dive on what's going on with
the Panama Canal and how it can affect
you okay so if you get value out of this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel let's get right into it
let me give you some facts on what we're
looking at number one I told you 40 of
containers that come to U.S travel
through the Panama Canal six percent of
all global trade goes through the canal
and Panama Canal is the busiest canal in
the world handling over 14 000 ships per
year by the way if you've never been
there I've been there before it's an
incredible experience seeing how ships
our elevated water is used to elevate
ships or lower ships that's the whole
concept of the canal it's unbelievable
what it does and how important it is to
U.S specifically you and I when we're
buying stuff the canal is expected to
reach capacity by 2030 and the expansion
of the canal which they're talking about
is expected to cost 5.25 billion dollars
and take five years to complete the
Panama Canal is the busiest canal in the
world handling over 14 000 ships here
which is roughly 40 ships a day and this
past July the number of ships allowed to
pass per day was lowered from 40 a day
give or take to 28 to 32 a day so now
what does this mean if you look at this
map here you'll notice there's two ways
for ships to come through from New York
to California so if you look at it the
short way is New York ship comes down
goes through the Panama Canal and goes
straight to La if the canal is
problematic these ships have to go all
the way South all the way south and then
come up to LA California and let's look
at what that really costs how long it
takes what's the problem with that
here's what it looks like with the
Panama Canal it's only
4970 nautical miles without it it's 12
350. with the canal it's only 10 to 14
days to go from New York to California
without it it's 30 to 35 days with it
it's only 262 000 roughly fuel cost
without it it's seven hundred and five
thousand dollars with it it's calm
conditions without it gets violent at
the bottom when they're going through so
obviously when you look at that number
it's kind of like imagine you're trying
to go home and the main freeway is
closed okay we're typically you're going
home it takes you 20 minutes to go there
and let you say five miles and it costs
you ten bucks for gas prices now if the
freeway is closed you have to go all the
way this way go all the way around how
many more miles is it how much more time
is it how much more gas are you going to
spend that's exactly what's going on
here but here they're bringing Goods
through canal now watch what happens if
they're going from China Shanghai to New
York here's what it looks like with the
canal as well as without the canal with
it it's roughly 12 000 miles without it
it's roughly 19 000 miles with it it
takes 22 to 25 days without it it takes
35 to 40 days with it it's only six
hundred thousand dollars of fuel costs
without it it's roughly 900 000 again
conditions come with it violent without
it so obviously it doesn't take a match
it needs to say I would much rather go
through Panama Canal because it's going
to be the most effective way now to
understand the importance of Panama
Canal how political of a project this
was how many people's lives and
businesses lives have changed we have to
go back and study the history of the
Panama Canal here's what we learned the
idea of a canal across the Isthmus of
Panama was proposed in the early 16th
century however it wasn't until 1880
that a French company began construction
on a canal and the project was abandoned
due to engineering challenge and
financial problems in 1904 the U.S took
over the project and completed it in 10
years in 1914. the canal was a major
engineering feat and it revolutionized
global trade the canal was also a major
strategic asset for the United States
during World War II it allowed the U.S
to rapidly deploy ships and troops
between the Atlantic and the Pacific
Oceans in 1977 the U.S and Panama signed
the torios Carter treaties which
transferred control of the canal to
Panama in 1999. now you and I were just
watching this video or living Our Lives
we don't know what it took to build a
canal we just kind of sit there and say
what's the big deal it's just a canal
it's not like it's that complicated of a
project you know how many people died
building a canal 22 000 people died
during the French Construction efforts
and an additional
5609 people died during the American
Construction for a total of 27
609 people died building the Panama
Canal so you may ask what did they die
from one the explosive to for the way
you have to do to build a canal it's not
the easiest thing to do they die from
mosquitoes they die from malaria they
die from black vomit internal bleeding
back pain extreme thirst a lot of
different things this was not the safest
conditions for these guys to build what
they build we've been benefit from it on
the backs of 27 000 people that died
building the Panama Canal in other words
they did The Impossible were the
beneficiaries of their efforts pretty
wild when you think about it but how
does the Panama Canal work so the Panama
Canal allows ships to Transit between
Atlantic and Pacific Ocean without
having to navigate the violent Waters
around the southern tip of South America
so one of the coolest thing is while
you're there they have a nice hotel the
Hard Rock Cafe they have a hard rock a
hotel there right next to Roberto
Duran's restaurant and they'll say hey
it's the only place in the world where
you can go have breakfast at the
Atlantic and have lunch at the Pacific
that's kind of what you get to do and
it's what a lot of people do when they
go there for vacation so now the lock
system the canal uses a system of locks
large chambers that can be filled or
emptied of water when a ship enters a
lock water is either pumped in to raise
the ship or let out to lower the ship
enabling it to Transit from sea level up
to the level of Gatlin Lake and
artificially created for the canal and
then back down to sea level on the other
side so each vessel that passes through
uses roughly 51 million gallons of water
from the lake so if you look at this
chart here to the left you'll see the
Atlantic Ocean to the right you'll see
the Pacific Ocean then you have the
mirafloris lake it's elevating the ship
to Gatlin Lake and then decreasing
lowering the ship to go to the Atlantic
Ocean the entire Transit through the
canal takes roughly eight to ten hours
depending on various factors again
pretty intense for what these guys have
built absolutely insane for engineers to
have built some like this number two
time and money saved impact on global
trade if the canal were inaccessible so
obviously the first one would be the
diversion of Rouse the second one will
be increased costs then it would be
supply chain disruptions economic impact
countries and ports that rely heavily on
trade through the canal would suffer
economically potential price increases
to you and I we would be paying more The
increased cost of shipping Goods could
lead to higher prices for consumers
around the world especially for products
heavily reliant on these shipping routes
so what are some of the products let's
take a look top 10 US Imports number one
printers 14 billion dollars of printers
then it's TVs then car parts and
sweaters furniture your video games
pills computers toys shoes and if you
look at the top 10 US Imports purely by
weight Furniture 4 million metric tons
and it's bananas artwork car parts coal
beer Oil Tires seeds tiles and by the
way how long can bananas sit there think
about it you think banana kids sit there
for three weeks you ever had banana at
the kitchen you leave it there for three
weeks what happens to it imagine we're
talking 2.8 metric tons of banana
sitting there for 21 days now watch the
exports what this looks like we're
shipping it out top 10 exports by value
number one is cars plastic construction
Machinery car parts cotton scrap metal
nuts pork wood pulp lab equipment and if
you look at it by weight number one is
scrap paper scrap metal wood pulp
plastic hay fresh paper cotton sugar
soybeans chicken this is catastrophic if
this goes from taking five and a half
days to six and a half days to 18 to 21
days so by the way maybe Saint Patrick
has 17 different problems I'm dealing
with right now you want me to be
thinking about the Panama Canal why
should this matter to me why should I
learn more about this because do you
remember what happened to the Suez Canal
when that one ship was stuck and every
minute of the day we were watching the
news showing us about this one ship in
Suez Canal and why you and I should be
worried about it and how everybody was
talking about it that's why that case
study is preparing us for that not to
happen with Panama Canal on March 23rd
to every given ship a container ship ran
aground in the Suez Canal blocking one
of the world's busiest shipping lanes
the ship wasn't robbed from China to
Netherlands when it ran aground in a
strong Windstorm it took six days to
free to ship during the time an
estimated 400 ships were delayed the
blockage caused an estimated 9.6 billion
dollars in losses to global trade to
tell you crazier stats about this how
much do you think the blockage of the
Suez Canal cost losses per hour 10
million an hour 100 million an hour how
about 400 million dollars an hour the
blockage delayed the delivery of
essential Goods such as food medicine
and Fuel and it also causes spike in the
price of oil and other Commodities it
also highlighted the vulnerability of
global economy to disruptions in
shipping what this incident I've ever
given in Swiss can now taught the world
a number of lessons about shipping and
Logistics including the global economy
is highly dependent on shipping shipping
disruptions can have a significant
impact on the global economy there's a
need for increased investment in
alternative shipping routes there's a
need for better risk management and
shipping there's a need for better
communication and cooperation between
shipping companies and governments and
by the way just like the Panama Canal
was revolutionary so was the Suez Canal
here's why the Swiss Canal is a man-made
sea level Waterway between a
Mediterranean Sea and the Red Sea it
connects the Indian Ocean with the
Atlantic Ocean through the Red Sea and
Mediterranean Sea respectively and
provides the shortest ceiling between
Europe and Asia if you look at this map
you'll notice you can either go from
Mumbai to London all the way around
South through Africa or you can go
through the Suez Canal straight shot to
London and save yourself 50 of the route
it was built over 10 years in the
mid-19th century the canal officially
opened up November 17 of 1860 39
originally constructed without locks the
canal was converted to a lock system in
1980 roughly 110 years later the Suez
Canal has won the world's most
strategically important waterways and is
vital to global trade the canal is also
a major source of revenue for Egypt
which operates and maintains it so now
this is a lot of problems we're talking
about is there any solution are they
making any kind of progress what's going
to be happening and you don't want to be
affected by this here's the good news
when you think about this capitalism
always works the Panama Canal makes
Panama roughly two billion dollars per
year in profits if they do this
expansion of the 5.25 billion dollars
they're going to make another billion
dollars now it's going to take five
years for them to build this so Panama
may say well we don't want to use the
money right now to put 5.25 billion
dollars another country may say you
don't want to do it no problem I'll give
you the money but we gotta own a piece
of it as well moving forward with the
profits Ben Panama is going to say no no
no no no then the world's going to say
well then hurry up and do it because you
kind of need us we're the customer
Panama may say well then what are you
going to do about if I don't do it it's
going to cost you more anyway so it's
going to be a power play on companies
can end up paying for it it's kind of
like relationships when they vendor and
a company the product producer and the
marketer they both need each other
because the product's working very well
they have to figure out a way to make it
work but regardless they got to move
fast the good news is just like the
Panama Canal Authority is undertaking a
5.25 billion dollar project to add a
third set of locks to the canal Suez
Canal Authority is also taking eight and
a half billion dollar development
project to widen and deepen the canal
this will also increase capacity and
reduce shipping costs on top of that
both the Panama Canal and the Suez Canal
Authority are investing in new
technologies to improve efficiency and
safety for example the Panama Canal
Authority is implementing an automated
lock system in the Suez Canal Authority
is installing new navigation AIDS both
Canal authorities are also working to
reduce the environmental impact of their
operations for example Panama Canal
authorities investing in water
conservation and flood control measures
and the Suez Canal Authority is working
to reduce pollution now the best part
about this is if Panama Canal doesn't
have another competition they can do
whatever they want to do the best part
when there's another competition they
have to really accelerate and get going
and there's possibly another route
through where the the Nicaragua Canal is
a proposed Canal that would connect the
Pacific Ocean to the Atlantic through
Nicaragua the canal is estimated would
cost 50 billion dollars to build and it
would take 10 years to complete so a lot
of these issues that's being dealt right
now they have to figure out a way to
address it but if we got another option
it's going to make that better for you
and I so next time you're in your car or
you're using something that we talked
about out of these products just make
sure for a second drop a prayer for the
people in Panama who are doing what they
do for us to be able to have the goods
that we have because it's not easy to do
what they're doing they're very
important anyways if you got value out
of this video give it a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel and number two
if you didn't watch the video we did
about hospitals and the Health Care
System why it's so expensive why they
almost have a monopoly if you've not
seen that yet click here to watch it the
numbers are staggering take care
everybody oh bye bye-bye
[Music]
thank you